all right so now moving on to part b
um we've got another inequality question
but of a different kind
it's given that a and b are real numbers
p and q are
imaginary numbers and then what you're
asked to do is to determine
with reasoning and i want to emphasize
that right now you can't just
substitute some numbers in and see what
happens we want to try and identify
what are the what are the appropriate
inequality signs to fit in here
to make these statements always be true
so how do we do this
i want you to have a look at these
expressions that you can see here
there's either going to be a less than
or greater than
less than or equal to greater than or
equal to right how are we going to get
some sort of
sense out of this being it seems like we
know so very little about the values of
a b
p and q well we want to think about
for example if p is a purely imaginary
number
then p squared has to be negative
right that's what it means to be purely
imaginary if you square that you're
going to get a negative number
over here same deal q squared is purely
sorry q is purely imaginary
so q has to be purely negative
now what does that mean well it's it's
going to tell me that i've got two
negative numbers over here
how does that relate to over here well i
need to do a bit of careful algebra to
see what's going on
so now that you're getting a sense of
how i'm going to solve this let me show
you my working
since a is real and p is purely
imaginary that makes ap
purely imaginary so you can see me
thinking about this thing here a squared
p squared
as the square of a paper right
and i can make the same argument about b
q it's purely imaginary
but if you've got ap and bq
independently being purely imaginary
then when you take the difference
they will also be purely imaginary or
they'll be equal to zero if the two
things are equal to each other
now if you've got ap minus b q being
purely imaginary or 0 then when you
square
it you're going to get something less
than 0 or or equal to 0. so i'm getting
this statement here
and then when i expand it you can see
i'm getting something like the result i
needed
i've got my a squared p squared on the
left hand side with the b squared q
squared
there's the 2abpq which i got by adding
this to both sides
and you can see the direction of the
inequality it's all good i've got a less
than or equal to
then when i have a look at the next one
have a look at the different combination
of numbers
if p and q are purely imaginary then
when you multiply them
then the i's will cancel with each other
and they just leave you
with a real component and of course we
already know that a and b are real so
its product
a times b must be also real so a b minus
p
q unlike a p minus
b q um ap a b minus b
p q man it's so easy to get it wrong
that has to be a real number
because the difference between two
different real numbers so real numbers
we know when you square them
they are greater than or equal to zero
unlike the imaginary ones up here which
are lesser than
or equal so once i expand that out same
deal happens i add two a b
p q to both sides and i've got an
inequality going in the opposite
direction so that's how i identify this
is greater than or equal to this is less
than or equal to
and very importantly to get those full
marks we need to see the reasoning you
couldn't just like state it
you had to show me why all right
let's move on to the next question over
the page
a very very succinct question but a ton
of work that comes out of it so what is
being asked to us
prove to marvel's theorem by
mathematical induction and then
please note non-negative integer
powers now i'm highlighting this because
the marvelous theorem as we remember
when we first proved it it's
actually true for all integer powers and
that's really one of the most handy
things about it
but in this case what we want to prove
is for non-negative integer powers
and the reason i'm doing that is
actually to do you a favor
in order to prove something by
mathematical induction that covers both
numbers to negative infinity and numbers
to positive infinity
because mathematical induction is a a
one directional process you start at a
base case
and then you just keep on going k plus
one k plus one k plus one right
in order to do all integer values you
have to start somewhere
and then do your proof by induction and
then using some other mathematical tools
you have to deal with the other side
mathematical induction even
ignored all of that because it just went
plus one plus one plus one it never goes
minus one okay so
me telling you just do it for the
non-negative integer powers is actually
giving you
a bit of a helping hand you only have to
do half of the proof the only catch is
a lot of you read non-negative and you
thought that it meant
positive there is a single number that
is neither negative
nor positive that's zero so therefore
the first problem that people had was
instead of testing correctly
n equals zero which was the correct
base case that you needed to verify
a lot of people tested n equals one and
as we saw earlier in this paper
and you've seen throughout extension one
n equals one is the normal place
where it starts but this was a trap for
young players we actually had to start
at n equals
0. so here is delmarva's theorem i've
stated it you ought to know it well
enough by now
so i'm going to test out the left-hand
side for n equals 0. you test out the
right-hand side
it's all good we assume our statement is
true
for n equals k and then we set to work
trying to prove the result true for n
equals k plus 1. now you can read this
yourself
and this is kind of the classic proof
i've even done a whole video lesson
about it
importantly what i've done is i've i've
sort of expanded out here but not like
completely
i've just taken this cos theta plus i
sine theta to the k and separated out
because
that is what my assumption includes i've
then done the substitution
of the assumption and then i just
basically expanded out
now i will make one note which is that
some students went straight from
this line here to this line
here which is semi-legitimate because
what you're doing when you're
multiplying complex numbers here's
cos theta plus i sine theta multiplied
by this other complex number
cos k theta plus i sine k theta when you
multiply complex numbers we know that
what you do is you add the arguments
and so you can see here one of the
arguments is theta one is k theta
off you go what i will caution though is
that if you did that you really need to
say something by
like you know multiplication of complex
numbers results in
the addition of arguments this is a
proof after all there's absolutely an
obligation on you
to be able to show the reasoning for
every single line that you write
in this particular working you can see
on the page i have avoided the necessity
for that by just sort of going the long
way around
i've just crunched out the algebra i've
just expanded these guys out
and then i've collected like terms and
then from here i've used trigonometric
identity so
just as an example oopsy daisy i'm
zooming in
you can see that this matches this is
like a sine a cos b
plus cos a sine b situation and what
that's equal to
is um this part here sine of a plus b so
that's a fairly classic extension 1
result
doesn't have to make any argument about
multiplication of complex numbers and
addition of arguments but either way is
fine i will admit
this is a fairly long and obvious way to
write it but once you get there
you get to say well that's equal to i
factor out the the theta
and that's the k plus one step so i'm
finished
most people had no trouble with the
induction the most common error was this
base case up here so please please
please
read carefully
okay and now um the last one in question
six it says consider the sequence
7 11 15 19 23 seems like a reasonable
enough sequence
i will never contain a square number
what a fascinating result what's going
on here right
um hopefully i made it obvious enough by
the terms that i included 7 11 15 etc
this is an arithmetic progression or an
arithmetic sequence i'm not adding
anything up right
i start at 7 and then i just add four
every single time okay
how do i prove that this sequence will
never
contain a square number well we did this
quite badly as a question because a lot
of people looked at this
and modeled around algebraically but
didn't really know what to do
this word never i'm highlighting it
because it's the big clue
when you see the word never it's kind of
a signal to you that
the tool in your toolbox for the nature
of proof that you need to use
is a proof by contradiction
what you want to show is that you can
assume that it does happen
somewhere eventually a square number
appears and what you can prove
is that that's ridiculous it leads to
something absurd there's a
self-contradictory thing
that means well i thought it might
contain a square number but i've shown
something ridiculous results so
therefore
my assumption must have been wrong it
can't possibly ever contain a square
number
so if you didn't realize you could do
this by proof by contradiction
you were in some trouble from the outset
let's have a look at how you actually
do it what i've done is proof by
contradiction begins with
the negation right so you have to say if
this particular sequence it's a 4n plus
3 sequence where
n starts out at n equals 1 so that's why
you get 7 to begin with and 11 and so on
if i assume the negation what that means
is there exists
some value of k such that in this
sequence and every term in the sequence
is in this form 4n plus 3
there should be a k squared in there
somewhere right it should appear
so this is my negation and what i want
to show is
that this assumption is clearly going to
lead to some problems
so um the negation is false that means
the original statement
is true so what i've then decided is
let's try it out by
exhaustion which is to say by cases
first i've thought about what happens if
k
is even let's see what happens if k is
an even number like 2 times something
then it's going to be 4p squared because
2p times 2p
but 4p squared is a multiple of 4 right
it's a that's an integer p squared and
then you multiply it by 4.
so this has to be some kind of whole
number multiple of 4
that means it can't possibly be 4n plus
3 because 4n plus 3 will never be a
multiple of 4. it's always one
short of a multiple of 4 and you can see
that in the examples here right
short of 8 short of 12 short of 16
shorter 20 and so on right
so i've proved that k can't possibly be
even
now let's see what happens if it's odd
if you try out k being odd
let's let it be 2 p 1 instead of 2 p you
do the expansion
there's k squared and then you can see i
can factor out 4 again from these
initial terms
so it's going to be 4 times an integer
plus 1.
well that can't possibly be 4n plus 3
because
4 times an integer plus 1 is 1 more than
a multiple 4 but this is 3 more
than a multiple of 4. you can see if i
go back to my question
you know uh one more than a multiple
four would be something like five
and then nine and then thirteen
and then uh what's my next one seventeen
and so on and you're always going to
miss you're always gonna be two off
because this sequence is 4n plus 3 and
what i've found
is apparently a 4n plus 1. if k
is odd what i've just determined is k
can't be even k
can't be odd that's a contradiction no
such k
can exist which is what i've written
here so that means that the assumption
which we began with is false the
negation is false which means the
original statement
is true um an original statement and its
negation has to have
opposite truth values so if one's true
the other's false
and vice versa so that's how you use it
it was slightly tricky that i didn't
tell you as a proof by contradiction but
part of the point here is that not just
can you use the right
proof tools but you know when the right
tool is appropriate
for the job